welcome everybody it's uh great to be
back and so many things to catch up on
and talk about just a few shows before
the end of the year and um before we
even talk about what's upcoming in 2022
uh we should talk about just the very
end of 2021 as far as the coronavirus
pandemic omicron just absolutely
everywhere
we don't even really have the latest
numbers because of the christmas holiday
where christmas eve and christmas day
case numbers are delayed we're just not
going to know the full scope for a few
days but what we saw right before new
year's eve just absolutely incredible so
we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about what is in essence
even without any real quote lockdowns
there are sort of de facto
self-prescribed soft lockdowns taking
place because of the number of people
that have been testing positive we're
going to talk about what's going on in
the uk as well so let's just jump right
into it um the last day for which we
have sort of like full data december
23rd
nearly a million cases globally 982 000
cases globally
uh with the average dropping a little
bit again because we we just don't have
full data from december 24th and 25th
yet we will soon
but
if there are one million cases a day
that we know about
the real number of cases with this
incredibly contagious omicron variant
could it be 2 million a day could it be
3 million a day even more
there's very wide speculation because of
number one the number of people that are
asymptomatic who wouldn't even think to
get tested and number two the number of
people with what we would call cold
symptoms who also may or may not get
tested
the real number could be two three
million a day
um fortunately for now
death numbers not increasing and this
again goes to the idea that this variant
is milder and less likely to lead to
death
uh the numbers globally are depending on
where you look
that this variant causes anywhere from
40 to 80 percent lower hospitalization
the 80 number coming from south africa
and we're told to look at that sort of
with care
uh because of the
skewing younger population that has been
infected there so that's globally in the
united states we saw again on december
23rd this incredible number
267 000 cases on december 23rd the
subsequent days because they are uh
holidays we still don't know the full
number but again same sort of math
applies if we knew about 267 000 cases
on december 23rd
the real number could be 500 000
dr fauci talking about could we see a
million cases a day in the united states
and the answer is probably yes
particularly when you look at the
positivity rate as one example houston
methodist reports more than half
of the pcr cova tests they're doing are
positive
and omicron makes up more than 90
of covered cases so
because for so many people
the symptoms are like a cold
it is
incredibly likely that if you have cold
symptoms you actually have covet and in
fact there's some data from the uk
half of colds will be covered warn uk
researchers that's from four days ago
and then two days ago there was another
report saying if you are in england
and you have a cold symptom
it's a 50 50 shot that you actually have
coronavirus and that particularly means
there are going to be a lot of
undiagnosed cases that never show up in
the numbers now
what is happening in terms of vaccine
evasion
we have some data from moderna which
says if you've had three doses you have
70 percent protection from symptomatic
infection
and that's the data there
when it comes to pfizer again this is
it's such a general statement but it
gives us a sense of where we are
uh this is a peer-reviewed article which
will be published in nature this is not
a pre-print this has been peer reviewed
and accepted
omicron extensively
but incompletely
escapes pfizer neutralization and you
can find this study and look at the
details
but certainly three doses better than
two and still
strong protection against serious
illness for the most part and then in
terms of the societal effect a very
interesting short article in the
atlantic published over the last couple
of days called omicron is pushing
america into soft lockdown
meaning we aren't seeing
mandates for businesses to close
but because of the number of people
testing positive there are lots of
businesses that are just closing
and um massive massive flight delays
over the holiday weekend
because of all of the pilots and crew
and and flight attendants on various
airlines delta was was hit really big
um
united i think as well maybe jetblue
a lot of flights being cancelled because
of the number of people testing positive
so it's not a mandated lockdown but
that's why it's being called a soft
lockdown so
what's the hope the hope is
that i mean what's the ideal scenario
the ideal scenario is
a less severe
much more like a cold or flu variant
very rapidly burns through the
population generating significant
immunity
at a minimal cost remember this this is
the dream
um and then we see a rapid decline in
cases as there is less unexposed
population for that variant to hit will
that happen we just don't know yet but
those are the numbers that we're seeing
so far and of course we're going to
follow it very very closely and we'll
have more
probably by tomorrow if not wednesday
we'll have a bigger sort of picture
of the real number of cases over the
holiday weekend which seems just
absolutely off the wall
um
here is a sort of portrait in
the childish
nature
of the modern american right wing
as many of you know this phrase let's go
brandon has become yes a cringeworthy
but a rallying cry nonetheless for the
american anti-biden right wing
let's go brandon if you're not familiar
with it there was a nascar driver named
brandon who was being interviewed after
a race
and the crowd was chanting f joe biden
but the reporter doing the interview
heard it as
let's go brandon instead of f joe biden
it's let let's go brandon so because it
was misheard now if you mean f joe biden
you say let's go brandon they've got
flags they've got shirts they've got all
sorts of merchandise of course it's
being monetized
it's not a good right wing meme unless
it's being monetized
joe biden and jill biden took phone
calls from people over the holiday to
say hello and to say you know different
things that was my phone that dropped um
and a guy got on the phone with joe
biden
and he actually said let's go brandon
and joe biden seemingly unaware of the
meme or at least choosing not to react
to it
um says yeah okay let's let's go brandon
and the right is absolutely aroused and
titillated by it they are foaming at the
mouth they think it's great except now
the guy who did it jared schmeck is
saying i was kidding
and it was just my free speech
and now i am being harassed so let's go
through the different elements of it
here is the video of this incident
taking place and joe biden seems to
either not care or not even be aware of
the meme
this isn't to you jared this is to the
kids that's right
i hope you have a wonderful christmas
yeah i hope you guys have a wonderful
christmas as well
let's go brandon
let's go brandon i agree hey by the way
where are you in oregon
where's your home
i think we lost him
yeah okay so
it's very dumb i mean if this is the big
wow
payoff
it's a very very dumb payoff but the
right loved it here is donald trump jr
saying it's amazing
and joe biden doesn't know what's going
on etc etc
i mean who would have thought joe biden
just gave guys like me the greatest
christmas present
ever
he has no idea what's going on folks so
i'm laughing and we're joking uh
and maybe this guy the guy who yelled
out the let's go brandon that guy's a
hero not all heroes wear capes unless
this guy's wearing a cape
which he should
uh absolutely amazing yeah so listen
first of all
if joe biden really didn't recognize
like let's assume joe biden's not doing
a poker face here let's assume he really
doesn't recognize the meme
i don't care whether presidents are
aware of the memes about them and the
jokes and the insults about them i
really don't care i care about policy
and i have many criticisms of joe biden
about policy which i've made on the show
but i don't care if joe biden doesn't
know about this if he does and he just
kept a poker face that's even even
funnier but the really funny part at the
end of the day
is the reaction from the guy who did it
jared schmeck
who is the guy that did this
claims he is quote being attacked for
utilizing my freedom of speech after he
essentially told the president to f
himself
the right loves to talk about tone
and demeanor
and behaving appropriately
and what the guy essentially did is tell
the president to to his face to go f
himself
if you have respect for the office
remember under george w bush oh even if
you don't agree with the specifics of
going to iraq you must respect the
office
it's another one of those values they
don't really care about uh now he sort
of says that he was kidding he says it
was just a joke i don't know what the
joke exactly is
and he says it was a reflection of his
frustration with biden's policies
including federal vaccine mandates
inflation
and global supply supply chain problems
when i watched that video it didn't seem
like when he said let's go brandon
that's what he was talking about schmeck
went on to say at the end of the day i
have nothing against mr biden but i am
frustrated because i think he could be
doing a better job schmeck is 35 and as
a former police officer now working for
the electrical company and says i mean
no disrespect to him
saying fu to the president
seems disrespectful
if you're talking about respect for the
office he says i understand there's a
vulgar meaning but i'm not that
simple-minded no matter how i feel about
him
uh
[Music]
just unbelievable unbelievable
um
it's uh it's another one of the oh he
clarified he's not a trumper but is a
free thinking american and follower of
jesus christ and says i'm being attacked
for utilizing my freedom of speech
once again
freedom of speech doesn't mean freedom
from the consequences of that speech
when you go and tell the president to
his face to f himself
there may be people who don't like that
and that speech might have consequences
there's no violation of your first
amendment the government is not limiting
or abridging your your ability to speak
in any way but there simply may be
consequences so this was his big moment
donald he he got an atta boy from donald
trump jr and he's also getting a lot of
people responding and saying you know
that that was actually pretty lame
uh nobody has violated his ability to
speak in fact most people never get the
opportunity to say anything to the
president jared schmeck did
and he said let's go brandon
make of it what you will
we have a couple of actually i have like
four or five different things to tell
you about that are upcoming first of all
we have sent out dozens of free t-shirts
to viewers i made the offer a couple of
weeks ago if you grab a new full-priced
yearly membership on our website before
the end of the year i will send you a
free t-shirt for a while due to the
pandemic we were seeing major delays in
shipping t-shirts the delays seem to be
gone
dozens of free t-shirts have gone out so
if you want to take advantage of getting
a free t-shirt
you can't be
an existing member this is for new
members you go to joinpakman.com you pay
the full yearly price not monthly and
then after signing up email info
davidpakman.com i will personally get
that t-shirt out to you uh just gotta
sign up by the end of the year number
two
on january 1st we are going to do a 2022
midterm kickoff special
it's going to be an insane membership
discount if you'd like to be notified
about it and to take advantage of it
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com that's number two number
three
the viewer town hall is rescheduled for
tomorrow why we wanted to do it a couple
weeks ago
when i was on the road my connection was
terrible we just couldn't make it happen
so it's rescheduled for tomorrow 6 p.m
eastern on the pacman live youtube
channel
and then lastly we are also going to be
doing
the next or i guess first for 2022
david pakman show chess tournament if
you want to play in the chess tournament
these are great community events
everybody's welcome it's going to be
tuesday january 11th at 6 00 pm eastern
i'll have more about that in the new
year but you can mark it on the calendar
the next chess tournament tuesday
january 11th 6 p.m eastern so we'll take
a quick break it's great to be back and
so much to talk with you about
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so i have to tell you i absolutely love
this story i i actually take pleasure in
bringing you this hilarious story as you
know republicans are currently the most
anti-vaccine group in the united states
there's no single factor
that predicts being against covet
vaccination as much as being a
republican republicans love to say well
look at anti-vacs in the black community
sure there's a history of that we've
talked about where it comes from but it
is republicans that are the most
anti-vaccine group in the united states
and for trump personally this is a
problem
he believes he created the vaccines now
he didn't but trump believes vaccines
work which they do but so many of his
followers don't believe that
prominent black conservative voice
candace owens scored an interview with
donald trump in which apparently she
thought that she and trump were going to
commiserate and sort of do their
anti-vac stuff together for the audience
but donald trump actually shuts it down
and there are like five or six different
interesting things here let's look at
the clip which has gone completely viral
and then we'll talk about it we see the
corruption right it doesn't seem like
anybody ever pays for the corruption and
right now we're seeing corruption live
even in terms of big pharma which is a
huge topic on the minds of mothers
especially you're seeing what's
happening at these school board meetings
where do you stand on these vaccine
mayonnaise and obviously i know that you
are you are pro-vaccine obviously you
did everything you could to get this
vaccine out i know it was one of the
greatest achievements we did less than
nine months to be able to do that but
but now it's taken a twist right it's
gotten now we went from this is a good
thing and people should have this option
to
military men you're going to have to
resign because you're not getting this
vaccine where do you stand on that well
i stand on forget about the mandates
that people have to have their freedom
but at the same time
the vaccine is one of the greatest
achievements of mankind we would have
had a 1917
remember the spanish flu killed perhaps
100 million people actually it ended the
first world war because the soldiers
were a lot of people don't know that the
soldiers got so sick it was a terrible
thing there were no vaccines they would
know anything i came up with a vaccine
with three vaccines all are very very
good came up with three of them in less
than nine months it was supposed to take
five to twelve years
and yeah people have died under cobit
this year by the way under joe biden
then under you and more people took the
vaccine this year so people are
questioning how the vaccine work but
some people aren't taking the ones the
ones that get very sick and go to the
hospital are the ones that don't take
the vaccine but it's still their choice
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected look the results of the
vaccine are very good and if you do get
it it's a very minor form
people aren't dying when they take the
vaccine
of children now even in this clip
trump lies trump tells a bunch of lies
in this clip but
specifically on the vaccines he brutally
schools candace owens but he's still
lying trump lies again about the spanish
flu he calls it the 1917 flu it was from
1918 he says it ended world war one it
didn't so he's still telling his lies in
this clip that we've heard from him so
many times but he's way more honest than
candace owens is about the vaccines
themselves but the most important lie is
that trump didn't come up with any
vaccines trump had nothing to do with
laying the groundwork for mrna
technology which has been researched for
decades and predates donald trump's
presidency predates trump's awareness of
it even
trump didn't sequence the virus he
didn't fund the sequencing of the virus
the u.s government under trump
pre-purchased some doses which many
countries do
and in fact the trump administration
didn't even pre-purchase enough doses
but lies aside trump is right
the people dying are overwhelmingly the
unvaccinated do some vaccinated people
die yes of course
but he is completely correct about that
and it's amazing to watch candice owens
squirm and move the goal post and say
well yeah but the mandates that's bad
right and trump says yeah the bad and
the masks on kids are bad right in terms
of yeah
those are bad but the vaccines work now
what happened after the fact is
incredible
and it shows you how corroded this
right-wing movement is
candace owens ended up being ridiculed
and attacked by almost everyone the left
ridiculed candace owens for being so
dumb about vaccines that trump had to
correct her
many on the right are mad at candace
owens for doing an interview with trump
which ended up being pro-vaccine at the
end of the day and a ton of
right-wingers are saying why didn't she
correct trump why didn't she give him
the evidence that she supposedly has so
candace owens has responded to this by
saying nah you know trump's just too old
to understand how bad vaccines are and
this is wild for two reasons which i'll
tell you in a moment but let's look at
what candace owens came up with to
explain what happened like sort of
believing that trump has like sold out
or that trump is a part of the big
pharma syndicate and my honest
assessment is that he just genuinely
believes
that the vaccines are good and he
believes that because he comes from a
generation like people you oftentimes
forget like how old trump is he comes
from a generation i've seen other people
that are older have the exact same
perspective like they came from a time
before tv before internet before being
able to conduct their independent
research you know and everything that
they read
in a newspaper if that was pitched to
them that they believed that that was a
reality and one of those things was you
know this push for vaccines and
believing that people were gonna die
without vaccines and so i believe that
his support of the vaccine is genuine
and it's not based in any corruption
at all i i think he actually believes
those things and people that are saying
how is he ignoring all the people that
are being injured and you know people
are sending rumble videos and all of
these you know websites obscure websites
i believe also that he only reads the
mainstream media news
believe it or not i do not believe that
trump reads um or partakes in any other
news sources um you know i don't believe
that trump is on the internet or you
know that he necessarily uses
like you know the the web to try to find
you know obscure websites i think that
he just relies on you know
typical mainstream sources so i don't
think that there's anything evil going
on there i just wanted to say that
because so many
donors supporters of his have are kind
of like questioning where all this is
coming from and i think he just
genuinely believes that um and he needs
to sit down and you know have a full
conversation with someone um i'm in i
was interviewing him in that
circumstance but he needs to have a
larger conversation
to really understand what's going on and
why
so many people are
just horrified so there it is trump's
just too old to understand why vaccines
are so bad
except a ton of the very anti-vaxxers
that follow trump are also trump's age
or close to it
and the anti-vac stuff is spreading on
facebook which skews dramatically older
how is trump ignoring all the rumble
videos candace owen asks it is beyond
parody but the real issue is donors she
mentions donors
her money
and everyone's money
is now at risk because of this and it's
also funny that she says trump needs to
go talk to someone about this i mean i
was interviewing him at the time but i
mean a larger conversation what she
means is she needs some other
anti-vaxxer
better versed on the talking points to
have a sit down with trump and try to
convince him actually the vaccines are
no good
at the end of the day what happened is
that her donors didn't like hearing the
truth from trump it destroyed her
narrative and that's it
and absolutely amazing conflicting lies
i tweeted about the fallout
uh over the weekend so it seems now
trumpists love trump because he
developed the vaccines which he didn't
but hate him because he said the vaccine
works which it does
this
completely triggered one time alex jones
at one time donald trump supporter alex
jones by the way the conspiracy theorist
and i want to talk about that next
so okay
we we looked in the last segment
at the cognitive dissonance being
experienced by many former and recent
trump supporters because trump stated
the simple fact to candice owens that
vaccines work and they are good and the
people dying of covid disproportionately
are unvaccinated all absolutely true
one of the people triggered by this is
conspiracy theorist alex jones now many
of you emailed me and said david you've
got to cover that alex jones wife was
arrested for domestic violence over the
weekend and
yes it's hypocritical that now alex
jones says this is private when
he didn't seem to think that the
specifics of what was going on and the
families of the victims of sandy hook
were private yeah i get the hypocrisy i
don't really care about alex jones
personal life what i do care about is
alex jones now completely turning on
donald trump
alex jones after this candice owens
donald trump interview
came in for a so-called emergency
christmas show
in order to
sound the alarm as he sees it about what
donald trump said
suggesting that donald trump might be
ignorant
he might be evil or he might be both
ignorant and evil and saying that trump
lied in his interview with candace owen
so check this out this is really
it's the stuff of dreams these factions
fighting in this way take a look this is
an emergency christmas day warning to
president trump
you were either completely ignorant
about the so-called vaccine gene therapy
that you helped ram through with
operation warp speed
or you're one of the most evil men who
has ever lived
to push
this toxic poison on the public
and to attack your constituents when
they simply try to save their lives and
the lives of others we're about to lay
out the basic incontrovertible facts
that what you told candace owens just a
few days ago is nothing but a raft of
dirty lies so jones goes on to recite
endless
debunked anti-vaccine lies which i'm not
going to play since i don't want to have
to debunk it piece by piece but jones
does mention that the vaccines are
so-called gene therapies now that's not
true
the vaccines don't change your genes
they don't stay in your body more than a
few days the vaccines are genetically
based therapies they're based on
messenger rna genetic material
the vaccines don't enter the cells of
the nucleus and we could go on but alex
jones is lying and that probably doesn't
surprise you
the most interesting part of this
is the people turning on trump over
something so uncontroversial many
right-wingers will try to soften their
anti-vaccine stances by saying i'm not
against vaccines i'm against mandates
how many times have we heard that
in his interview trump said
people should still have freedom not to
take it but the vaccines are good and
the vaccines work
and he's still getting crushed so all of
the people saying we're only against the
mandates not the vaccines
in the interview trump said i'm not
against i'm not uh for the mandates i'm
just for the vaccine and they're still
going nuts trump said the vaccines are
good and they work and alex jones is
saying this is evil and these are gene
therapies so were they against the
mandates only or are they actually
against the vaccines it seems pretty
clear
as i've said before
the more that these people are fighting
with each other
the less they'll be able to put together
functional 2022 campaigns now my
preference would be
that democrats help themselves in 2022.
it's unclear whether that's going to
happen
so any help that we can get from the
right i will gladly take this also shows
us that the idea of big tent on the
right
is completely bogus if you veer off
script for a day
they come right at you and trump even
tells lies in that clip with candace
owens lies that typically titillate his
followers
but just saying hey the vaccines work
it's mostly unvaccinated people that are
dying it sent a huge portion of his
followers into a tailspin it's hard to
imagine this ends well for them and
that's a good thing it's a sort of
circular firing squad
that is buying more and more ammunition
to use against each other
also
consider how trump said nutty things for
four years and these people were calm he
says vaccines work and they go nuts
trump said what if we nuke a hurricane
he drew with a sharpie on a hurricane
map he said what about injecting bleach
you know i could list 30 things
they're
explaining it all away throughout
trump's presidency trump says vaccines
work and suddenly they implode these are
incredible times that we are living in
the hope is
this damages republicans in 2022
we'll have these clips on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
make sure you're following me at
david.pacman as well
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so while i was away we had this uh
i mean it's i know people laugh at me
when i say it but it's the right word we
had this kafka-esque moment
where during another one of these
half-sold out public events with donald
trump and disgraced former fox news host
bill o'reilly donald trump said vaccines
are good and i got the booster and the
crowd started booing him and dr anthony
fauci was on cnn over the weekend and he
was asked what did you make of that and
basically dr fauci couldn't believe how
stupid trump supporters who booed are
now that's my characterization to be
clear dr fauci's words were were a
little softer he said he was dismayed
and he was stunned now at this point
being stunned by what trump supporters
do
we're kind of long past being stunned uh
we're going to look at that clip in a
moment but as a reminder here's the
moment from the trump bill o'reilly
event at which trump and o'reilly say
we've gotten the booster and the crowd
boos and trump tries to calm them down
but look we did something that was
historic
we saved tens of millions of lives
worldwide we together all of us
not me we we got a vaccine done three
vaccines done and tremendous
therapeutics like regeneron and other
things that have saved a lot of lives
we got a vaccine done in less than nine
months it was supposed to take from five
to 12 years because of that vaccine
because of that vaccine
millions and millions of people i think
this would have been the spanish flu of
1917 where up to 100 million people died
this was going to ravage the country far
beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved
tens of millions of lives take credit
don't let them take that away from you
okay so the president made news do you
agree with that
right
both the president and i are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes i got it too okay so
don't don't don't um know
that's all it's a very tiny group of
okay so there it is trump vaxxed
trump boosted it's an accomplishment
it's great
and the crowd is booing fine so fauci
also in this clip that we're going to
look at was asked about the candace
owens trump interview which we looked at
earlier in the show in which she does
the anti-vaxx stuff
and trump goes no the vaccines are good
so i played that clip earlier but just
as a reminder so we have it all in this
clip here is that clip again which dr
fauci was asked about and will react to
we see the corruption right it doesn't
seem like anybody ever pays for the
corruption and right now we're seeing
corruption live even in terms of big
pharma which is a huge topic on the
minds of mothers especially you're
seeing what's happening at these school
board meetings where do you stand on
these vaccine mayonnaise and obviously i
know that you are you are pro-vaccine
obviously you did everything you could
to get this vaccine out i knew it was
one of the greatest achievements we did
in less than nine months to be able to
do that but where but now it's taken a
twist right it's gotten now we went from
this is a good thing and people should
have this option
to
military men you're going to have to
resign because you're not getting this
vaccine where do you stand on that well
i stand on forget about the mandates
that people have to have their freedom
but at the same time
the vaccine is one of the greatest
achievements of mankind we would have
had a 1917
remember the spanish flu killed perhaps
100 million people actually it ended the
first world war because the soldiers
were a lot of people don't know that the
soldiers got so sick it was a terrible
thing there were no vaccines they would
know anything i came up with a vaccine
with three vaccines all are very very
good came up with three of them in less
than nine months it was supposed to take
five to twelve years
and yeah people have died under cobit
this year by the way under joe biden
then under you and more people took the
vaccine this year so people are
questioning how you know the vaccine
work but some people aren't taking the
ones the ones that get very sick and go
to the hospital are the ones that don't
take the vaccine but it's still their
choice
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected look the results of the
vaccine are very good and if you do get
it it's a very minor form people aren't
dying when they take the vaccine about
the masking of children okay so those
are the that's the material those are
the two clips
that dr fauci is asked about
and he was asked about it yesterday on
abc so check out what dr fauci had to
say
you know it was interesting on this
question of vaccination i'm sure you saw
president trump former president trump
uh said came out and said that he uh had
received the booster shot he actually
got booed a little bit by the crowd of
support of his supporters as he said
that and now uh you know there's another
interview he just did uh with a
conservative outlet with candace owens
where he really pushed back on the idea
that the vaccine is not protecting
people he said that the people going to
hospitals
are
uh are the ones largely that haven't
been vaccinated you don't die if you get
the vaccine that those were those were
donald trump's words i mean it'll be
interesting to see if his supporters
listen to that
well i certainly hope so uh john we'll
take anything we can get about getting
people vaccinated i was a bit dismayed
when former president trump came out and
made that statement
and his followers boot him which i was
stunned by that i mean given the fact of
how popular he is with that group that
they would boo him which tells me how
recalcitrant they are
about being told what they should do and
i think
that he's continuing to say that people
should get vaccinated and articulating
that to them
in my mind is a good thing i hope he
keeps it up yeah let's hope he says it
loudly now
yeah
trump telling people to get vaccinated
is basically a win-win unless you want
republicans to die and i know some of
you do but that's not my that's not my
thing okay so i'll explain
some of trump's followers are going to
hear trump say this stuff
and they will actually go and get
vaccinated and as a result fewer people
are going to die overall and that's good
and some of the trump supporters that go
and get vaccinated will also
prevent spread to some degree
and it's a good thing from a public
health standpoint so some people will be
convinced because trump said this and
that's fine
the ones who won't do it
and who get mad at trump for saying hey
the vaccine's good
they may become so furious and
disaffected
that they might abandon trump in 2024 if
trump runs and that's also a good thing
because it might weaken
a possible trump 2024 run
it might embolden a serious viable
primary challenger to trump in 2024 if
trump does run and that can only be good
for the left if the left knows how to
take advantage of it now some of you
might say this is the third option right
some of you might say david this is bad
we want republicans to die i don't want
anyone to die so i see this as a good
thing all around
and maybe it will keep us making
progress on the pandemic which by the
way with how contagious omicron is
uh it appears as though we are going to
make progress regardless of what anyone
wants to see and we're going to have an
update on that
either tomorrow or wednesday again once
we get the the latest data from the
holiday weekend now what trump could
have and should have done
would have been
to keep being pro-vaccine on the way out
of office like all along he could have
said hey i'll be gone but you got to get
those vaccines and of course he didn't
do that and it's too late to go back but
if trump had maintained this sort of
perspective or had this sort of
perspective as he was leaving office and
in every single interview that he did
just after leaving
it probably prevents a bunch of these
republicans from becoming so anti-vaxxed
in the first place but that's the ideal
we're not in the ideal scenario
obviously so this is another example
of when
the monster's creator
loses control of the monster that they
created and there's no way to undo it
there's no
sort of putting the genie back in the
bottle or whatever analogy you want to
use so very interesting and fouchy
visibly stunned by what we saw there
well uh omicron is everyone
omicron is everywhere rather and we're
going to talk more about that a little
bit later this week but we have another
one of these tragic stories in michigan
when the state issued shutdowns for
restaurants there is a diner that
decided to stay open and the diner
stayed open because the diners owner
john parney decided to ignore the law
so the quincy diner in quincy michigan
stayed open and john parney the 62 year
old owner is now dead of covid
after two months of fighting it now i
have to tell you
this one is different from the typical
anti-vaxx nut believes covet is fake and
dies the guy was anti-vaccine but this
particular story is extra uh tragic and
i'm not joking here this is not a joke
back in december
when parney said i'm gonna keep the
restaurant open
he said
my wife is fighting stage 4 colon cancer
we depend on the restaurant to help
subsidize billing and all of that my
employees need that of course if i'd
have stayed closed much longer
i'd have lost the business
so this is actually a story about many
things and it's in great part a story
about access to health care
we say
with universal healthcare there's no
breaking bad right walter white doesn't
need to start cooking meth to pay for
his treatment if there's universal
health care and whenever i say that some
of you will write to me and you'll say
david well walter white was cooking meth
to leave his family a nice nest egg not
just to pay for medical treatments fine
but walter white used the meth money to
pay for expensive treatments as well and
this guy parney didn't just need to keep
the restaurant open to pay for his
wife's cancer treatment he was also
working full-time at a casino
now it is also true that parney was not
vaccinated and that is 100 his choice
he told his family he planned to get
vaccinated after he ended up in the
hospital with kovid he never made it to
that because he died
and now there's a gofundme for his final
expenses and for his wife's continued
cancer treatment which is still ongoing
she is she is still with us
so this is really a story about how much
of a mess this country is in you've got
a 62 year old who's unvaccinated by
choice that's part of the
weaponized disinformation about the
vaccines he catches covet and it's
really bad that's one story we've heard
that story a bunch of times
and that's what happens to tons of
people that's why you get vaccinated
there's no doubt about that but there's
the other story which is he was working
at his restaurant and keeping it open
and working at a casino
to pay for his wife's cancer treatment
and by the way if your wife has cancer
why on earth would you not get a vaccine
in order to protect her
you care enough to keep the restaurant
open
in defiance of the law to pay for her
treatments but you won't even get
vaccinated to protect her so there's a
lot wrong with what this guy did and
there's a lot wrong with this country
but this is also a story about the
broken health care system as much as it
is a story
about anti-vaccine ignorance as we have
been talking about for a while at this
point in time so another tragedy
another ignorant guy who didn't get
vaccinated but also a really depressing
story about the state of affairs with
health care in the united states
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at dpakman
and davidpakmanshow we're on instagram
david.pacman join the reddit community
at davidpakman.com reddit and you can
also find the david pakman show on
facebook
discord
and tick tock it's almost too easy
so this you have to see
in advance of the big christmas holiday
this weekend the former president donald
trump sat down with former arkansas
republican governor mike huckabee
also the dad of trump's own former press
secretary sarah huckabee sanders who
herself is now running as a republican
for governor of arkansas i don't think
i've ever seen an interview like this
and a huge part of the interview is
about a fake issue then that issue is
the so-called war on christmas there's
music playing in the background mike
huckabee is really focused in on
christmas and sort of makes trump out to
be like a hero i guess for saving
christmas for bringing back christmas
see if you can i challenge you see if
you can determine the number of lies
told here let's just jump right into the
first clip
[Applause]
america had gone to a long period where
people quit saying merry christmas it's
all happy holidays
you deliberately changed that
and openly said merry christmas we're
going to say it again
part of my campaign mike you know the
country had started with this woke i
guess a little bit before that yeah
and it was embarrassing for
stores to say merry christmas you'd see
these big chains they want your money
but they don't want to say merry
christmas and they'd use reds and then
use whites and snow but they wouldn't
say christmas and when i started
campaigning this was in 2015
when i started campaigning i said you're
going to say merry christmas again and
now people are saying it
of course they're not saying a lot of
other things like george washington
abraham lincoln thomas jefferson you
know those names are being obliterated
because of craziness
so
there was a long period where no one
said merry christmas that's not true
trump said that part of his campaign was
saying merry christmas now that may be
true
but how pathetic is that if it's true
trump's saying it like it's something to
be proud of but it's not it's a joke if
you ran on we're going to say merry
christmas again which by the way we
nobody ever stopped saying merry
christmas it was never embarrassing for
stores to say merry christmas there were
some stores who chose the more inclusive
happy holidays but like who really cares
and then trump says they also aren't
saying things like george washington
abraham lincoln and thomas jefferson
who isn't saying those names and also
what do those names have to do
with this time of the year like i said
we're reaching this is sort of like
uncharted territory in lies about what
is happening in society and culture
people aren't saying these names and
huckabee just nods along like this makes
sense let's continue into the next clip
but they are saying merry christmas
again we got that that was a big part of
what i was doing and say i would say it
all the time during that period
that we want them to say
merry christmas don't shop at stores
that don't say merry christmas and i'll
tell you we brought it back very quickly
you really did and i think a lot of
people appreciated that it was a part of
the american culture it was a part of
who we are it wasn't uh to exclude
anybody it was just simply a celebration
of what america does at christmas and
america and the world but america loves
christmas yeah and whether you're muslim
whether you're christian whether you're
jewish everyone loves christmas and they
say merry christmas until these crazy
people came along and they wanted to
stop it along with everything else so i
was very proud of that actually remember
i used to say we will say merry
christmas again in front of these
massive crowds of people so trump says
it like it's an administrative
accomplishment we brought back
saying merry christmas christmas and he
says even muslims i don't know why you
pronounce it that way muslims like
christmas as well which is really
something else i still don't know who
cares about this and every time i say
this was not ever a real issue
a couple people will email me and
they'll say david no there was a
cultural backlash at one point where
the woksters were saying you shouldn't
say merry christmas or whatever
almost no one ever cared about this i'm
jewish i recognize most people are
christian by culturally ethnically i'm
saying
when someone says merry christmas to me
and it has happened a lot in the last 10
days
i don't get offended
i just don't say it myself i'll either
say
thank you and walk away
if someone says happy holidays i'll say
likewise happy holidays have a good new
year and sometimes if someone says merry
christmas to me i'll say oh happy
hanukkah like if they're wishing me
something about what they celebrate i'll
wish them happiness for what i celebrate
like it's no big deal people will laugh
it's just it just doesn't matter and
trump is calling this one of his major
accomplishments if you can imagine that
now it is true
he doesn't really have any other
accomplishments to speak of so maybe the
fact that
he says merry christmas is like all he
has to cling to or something like that
there's one more clip in this one
huckabee thanks trump
for not just saying merry christmas
but for giving people
good christmases and this is like
i mean you know this is like north
korean propaganda
huckabee really should be blushing
behind that white beard that he is now
sporting take a look at this
president i want to say because of you a
lot of americans have had some great
christmases
you helped rebuild the economy pride in
our country
made us a strong military once again
stood up to china when i think of all
the ways that you led this country
energy independent for the first time in
75 years no longer
i think a lot of people are
right now saying i wish donald trump was
president right now this year for
christmas what a great christmas present
that would be well it's been very sad
when you look we were energy independent
and now they're going to opec again and
and they're begging for oil
and the gasoline price was 1.87 and now
it's in california 7.50 cents a gallon
and it's going to follow that and i said
that during the debates i said when you
watch what they do to energy when you
watch what they do with inflation
inflation is a killer
and so many other things it's it's very
sad
to see what's happening but
our country will survive it
and i really believe we're going to be
greater than ever before a beautiful
christmas message about begging opec for
oil
still trump talking about 750 gas in
california which by the way i was in
california last week i looked everywhere
for the seven dollar
77 cent gas trump talked about now i'm
not saying it never existed maybe there
was some place in california where super
premium was 7.77 i couldn't find it most
expensive i saw was 6.49 let by the way
i didn't put that in my rental car i'm
putting the cheap stuff in the rental
car i can tell you that for sure okay so
a complete
and total
propaganda piece there on newsmax and
everybody involved should be completely
embarrassed by it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p i do want to let
people know i came back from my week off
to 1100 unlistened to voicemails 1100.
it's going to take some time to go
through them all
i did get a couple of voicemails about a
particularly deranged anti-vaccine
bit of propaganda uh i'm gonna play one
of those voicemails for you this one is
from troy york who really has fallen for
the anti-vac stuff take a listen see if
you can even understand it and then i'll
explain it and tell you what's going on
uh mr pacman i would like for you to
make
the nfl
players thomas
at the age of 33
has died
and most likely this has to do with him
being forced
to take the vaccination
the number of people being killed
and dying after taking the vaccine
is untold because the media doesn't tell
us they are paid back to tennis
but it must be in the hundreds of
thousands
and the american people are not stupid
they know that these vaccines are an
attempt to kill much of the population
as much as possible
a large chunk of the least and so that
that's you you probably get the point
that's uh probably going to be enough
so the nfl player demarius thomas did
pass away and that's very tragic
um
it had nothing to do with the covet
vaccine as far as there is any evidence
whatsoever to be uh presented
um
and the way that this spreads
is unclear
but he had been having seizures for
quite a period of time
uh his cousin believes that he died from
a seizure or complication related to it
and there's no
reason at all to think that it had to do
with a vaccine i don't even know if he
was vaccinated but let's let's presume
he was
uh as i think most nfl players are at
this point in time
the way that this spreads
is that initially
it's the opportunism of
young person who should be the picture
of health because he's a football player
has died
and he was found dead it wasn't uh a
murder
it wasn't a car accident it was well he
had been having seizures and he was
found dead and we're still figuring out
the cause of death so it's an
opportunity to say
young guy dies no explanation must be
the vaccine that that's number one
then
in the news articles it is accurately
said as of right now the exact cause of
death is unclear so you you've got the
opportunity and then you have
for what for a conspiracy theorist
the absence of evidence which starts to
be used as evidence remember that's a
key to conspiracism and conspiratorial
thinking if there's evidence for
something you say look here's evidence
if there's absence of evidence you say
that absence is an opportunity to assert
my belief about an explanation in this
case
we don't yet have the official cause of
death and so it's a vacuum into which
the conspiracy can be inserted
and then of course
when all you have is a hammer everything
looks like a nail
and if you want to just attack vaccines
any death in which there is an
unexplained immediate cause of death you
say well it must have been the vaccine
so that's like the cycle that's the
cycle as it is
um and of course there is no evidence
whatsoever for it which is the most
important thing to keep in mind but
unfortunately a lot of people i i hadn't
even heard about
the fact that it was being asserted
that the vaccine was involved here i
googled it there's a ton of wacky people
making the assertion absent any evidence
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today i'm going to tell you what i was
up to during my break last week a lot of
really interesting things to tell people
about make sure you are a member so that
you get the bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com i will again restate my
offer to you that if you sign up for a
new listen to the keywords here a new
full price
yearly membership for 60
if you sign up and pay a dollar 80 for
your first month you don't qualify okay
this is new full price yearly we will
send you a free t-shirt of your choice
just email info davidpakman.com after
signing up tell me the t-shirt style
color
and size you want as well as your
mailing address we'll get those right
out to you we also are doing a january
1st midterm kickoff membership special
if you've been thinking about signing up
and waiting for just the perfect time
everything has to align for you to sign
up
this january 1st is a great day to do it
we'll be doing a huge membership special
we'll be notifying everybody on our
newsletter by email on the morning of
january 1st so just get on my newsletter
a mailing list at davidpakman.com
and then as a final reminder tomorrow we
will be doing the rescheduled final town
hall of the year it'll be streaming live
on the pacman live youtube channel 6 pm
eastern 3 p.m pacific tomorrow december
28th hope to see all of you there but
for today we will talk to you on the
bonus show and you can sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access
you